staying in shape is something every
man's got to deal with sometimes I wish
I was a woman so I could look so pretty
with my boobs and nice butt and so I
could cry whenever I wanted and not have
to wait until my girlfriend even
something in the garage strap in and get
ready for a non-stop pro ride of manse
plosive proportions
this is tqez how to be a man today and
eagerly shows us how to get in shape you
are here not a minute too soon this is a
guy that needs a gym man look at this
puny puny nothing nowhere no muscles hey
I think somebody needs some glasses I'm
wearing glasses it was a joke oh okay I
get it we're gonna make some jokes today
too I guess the treadmill gives you an
opportunity to run without having to go
anywhere all right now what I do is I
start off at a cold dead run no
stretching no warm-up at a 13 clip I
just get on here and I go one question
yes really quick and I kind of asked you
I just noticed that woman's gym
not exactly back in 2008 I was on my way
to the courthouse actually I look and I
see this place just gals this place yes
what Wow no like men are literally not
allowed in there that's off in America
they don't have bathrooms that are just
for men exactly next thing you know I
get a court order they have to let me
join this gym what I did Wow yep and a
lot of the women who work out here are
not all that happy about it you're doing
God's work man well it's very hard you
know I'm not gonna compare myself to
Rosa Parks
now this is definitely new to me what is
this this is called a plie it comes from
the world of dance my friend watch
everything go yeah yeah well actually
the moaning is not so much because it's
hard I've known a lot in the gym just to
create a zone around me that nobody
wants to come in you're not mentally
tough I won that round you just walked
away from your workout this this whole
thing about just gals I think this is
sort of a spiritual quest and I'm gonna
try to get inside right now I'm gonna
know just bear with me let me ask you
this what did your mother do for work my
mom ran a women's gym
Andy Daly
yeah thank you so much for being here
that's great awesome tips on working out
checkout issue on Comedy Central but
hang on buddy we're not done yet
we're still gonna hit the showers let's
go what you are not going in the ladies
locker room all right this is not a joke
there are women and they're naked say
I'm going home okay great I won't take a
shower I'll just use the steamer more
awesome videos that teach you how to be
a man subscribe to our YouTube channel
and follow us on Twitter